welcome to my flagship restaurant Gordon
Ramsay here in London please come inside
right
welcome to the dining room now look at
this so it's small as intimates
literally 14 tables 44 seats so it
functions five days a week there's 25
staff that run the dining room and 25
cooks in the kitchen
the dying room is tiny but super
powerful it is neat unique and the
atmosphere is electrifying
now let's go through the engine room
shall we come through to one of the most
gorgeous kitchens anywhere on the planet
because I designed it myself trust me
is the kitchen like no other
right come on take a look at this
welcome to the engine room trust me it's
built like a Ferrari now headed up by
Matt I've a good set about 21 years we
rebound this place this year and two
million dollars the kitchen let me take
you around Matt what are you guys James
good morning so this is its open plan
kitchen Matt controls the past outside
we've got the fish to meet the sauce the
garnish pasture and then through the
back there is the most amazing pastry
but it was designed especially because
wherever I am or Matt is in the kitchen
you can see everything because there's
no obstruction so from any angle the
kitchen we can cook with our eyes coming
here is like standing in the most
amazing sacred Church because this is a
gas we praise them every morning and
this is the emblem this is the one the
crest every chef in this kitchen has
that tattooed on their back so you wanna
see mine
I'm joking now look see down the side
here and this is where the pastry is
some of the most talented young Chefs
anywhere and it comes today one of guys
ladies we're good
excellence and that's it the engine room
of Russian Gordon Ramsay celebrating 21
years this year and this is where it all
started I'm so happy you're here
[Music]